[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
وتتفاعلوا اخرى
على اجواء مونديال قطر 2022 والبدايه من
هذه الصور من ساد البيت الذي يستضيف حصريا
اذن ضربه البدايه لكاس العالم قطر 2022
بين قطر والاكوادور مساء غدا الاحد
اذا الاستاذ البيت اما منطقه البدع
بالعاصمه القطريه ابيع صور تاتينا مباشره
تزامنا مع الافتتاح الرسمي لمهرجان
المشجعين في مونديال قطر
الى الحي الثقافي كتارا احد ابرز المعالم
السياحيه في دوله قطر والمنتظر ان يستقطب
عشرات الالاف من الجماهير التي ستحضر كاس
العالم
ونذهب بكم الى كيف عاصمه الاكوادور وسحر
رئيسيه تقام فيها فعاليات ثقافيه تتضمن
شاشه كبيره تعرض مباراه الغد بين قطر
والاكوادور
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قبل ساعات على صافره البدايه لانطلاق حدث
كاس العالم قطر 2022 رئيس الفيفا يتهم
اوروبا بالنفاق في تقييمها لاوضاع العمال
ويطالبها بالاعتذار عما فعلته بالعالم
خلال عقود ويؤكد جاهزيه قطر التامه
لاستضافه افضل بطوله لكاس العالم وتوفير
اجواء امنه للجماهير
انظروا العالم تتجه الى قطر
مع اتمام من جميع الاستعدادات لاستضافه
كاس العالم غدا الاحد الدوحه تستقبل اكثر
من مليونيه زائر من مشجعين كره القدم حول
العالم واللجنه المنظمه تؤكد استكمال جميع
التدابير والجهوزيه التامه للحدث واستخدام
تكنولوجيا متقدمه لاول مره في تاريخ
البطوله
[موسيقى]
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني في كيف يجري
محادثات هي الاولى من نوعها مع زيلانكي
ويعد بمزيد من الاسلحه بينها انظمه دفاع
جوي كبير مساعد رئيس الاوكرانيه يقول ان
السلامه مع روسيا لن يكون ممكنا الا
بالسعاده شبه جزيره القرم ودمباز
وموسكوتام في اغلاقها باب التفاوض وتتهمز
الانسكي بمحاوله جرها لمواجهه مع النيتو
وتقول ان الغربه لا يريد قطيعه كامله
قبيله بحثي مجلس الامن او تصعيد الكوريه
الشمالي واطلاق الصواريخ البالستيه كيم
جونغ اون يرد على استخدام قاذفات
الاستراتيجيه في مناورات واشنطن وصول
وسوكيو باختبار صاروخ بالستي عابر للقارات
ويلوح باستخدام اسلحه النوويه اذا تعرضت
كوريا الشماليه لهجوب النووي
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا رسائل كاس العالم لكره
القدم التي تنطلقوا منافساتها يوم غدا
الاحد لاول مره على ارضه دوله عربيه
ومسلمه والاستطلاع ارائكم بهذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث برايكم
ما الذي يتصدر النتائج المتوقعه لاستضافه
بلد عربيا ومسلما كاس العالم لاول مره نحو
سبعه واربعين في المئه رجحوا تصدر الثمار
الثقافيه لهذا الحدث بينما قال قرابه 20%
ان النتيجه الاهم هي تجاوز الصوره النمطيه
للعرب والمسلمين اما نحو اثنين وثلاثين في
المئه اختاروا ابرازه قدره العرب على
تنظيم حدث رياضيا عالمي النتيجه الاهم
المتوقعه لمونديال قطر 20 22 هذا سؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الركنيه
[موسيقى]
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وان تتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وقبل بدايه جولتنا الاخباريه الى هذه
الاجواء التي تستعد قطر والعالم على وقعها
لاستقبال حدث كاس العالم غدا احتفالاته في
مناطق عده بقطر وتدفق للمشجعين الذين
نشروا اجواء حماسيه اشبه باستعراض
احتفاليه تحمل بصمات بلادهم كل هذا
بالتوازي مع اكتمال تحضيرات الاحتضان كاس
العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا استنكر رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم جاني انفانتينو الانتقادات المتعلقه
بكاس العالم ووصفها بانها دروس اخلاقيه
تنمو عن النفاق و خلال مؤتمر صحفي في
الدوحه قال انفنتينو ان الاوروبيين عليهم
الاعتذار عما فعله في العالم خلال عقود
الماضيه قبل اعطاء دروس في الاخلاق
مني مني سمعنا العديد من الدروس الاخلاقيه
من الاوروبيين ومن دول غربيه انا مواطن
اوروبي واعتقد ما قمنا به اوروبيين على
مدار 3000 سنه يتعين علينا الاعتذار عنه
على مدار 3000 سنه المقبله قبل ان اعطي
دروسا للاخرين هذه الدروس الاخلاق
هل تحدثت اي منها عن حقوق العمال هل حقا
يكترثون لظروف العمال لا احد يقترب لكن
الفيفا ولاكون منصفا قطر
هم يمكنهم الدفاع عن انفسهم انا هنا كي
يدافع كره القدم والعداله
واضاف رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم ان
الظروف العمال في اوروبا ليست الافضل
الى اوروبا وصلوا في ظروف صعبه بعضهم توفي
في التاريخ لن نسمح لاي عامل من هذه الدول
الاسيويه اي يعمل بطريقه شرعيه ونعلم كم
هو عدد العمال غير الشرعيين في دولنا
الاوروبيه وظروفهم التي هي ليست الافضل
واكد رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
مجاني انفانتينو جاهزيه دوله قطر التامه
لاستضافه افضل كاسا للعالم وكذلك استعداد
القائمين على البطوله لتوفير اجواء امنه
للجماهير
الدوحه جاهزه قطر جاهزه ستكون افضل بطوله
فهذا ما يريده المشجعون هناك اكثر من
100,000 شخص مستعدون للحدث الكبير
واستقبال اكثر من نصف مليون زائر لمتابعه
البطوله جميع القائمين على البطوله
مستعدون لخدمه ضيوف المونديال وتوفير
اجواء امنه لهم في كافه المناحي من
الاقامه والمعيشه والطعام
وقال الفنتينو ان قطر تطورت كثيره في مجال
حمايه حقوق العمال انه كان على الاطلاع
على التطور الذي حققته قطر في مجال حقوق
الانسان
الماضيه يجعلني استحضر قصه الشخصيه انا
ابن عائله من العمال والدي كان يعملان في
ظروف صعبه للغايه ليس في قطر ولكن في
سويسرا اتذكر جيدا ولا اتحدث عن نظام
عنصري بل اتحدث عن سويسرا حيث عاش اجدادي
وعامله هناك كيف كانت الظروف معيشتهم وما
الحقوق التي كانوا يحصلون عليها وما
الحقوق التي حرم منها اتذكر عندما كنت
طفلا كيف كان العمال المهاجرون يتم
التعامل معهم عندما يعبرون الحدود بحث عن
عمل وماذا كان يحدث بجوازاتهم وفحوصاتهم
الطبيه وعندما اتيت للدوحه اول مره بعد
انتخاب لرئاسه الفيفا اردت رؤيه احدها
هؤلاء العمال واماكن سكنهم واسترجعت حينها
طفولتي وقلت للمسؤولين في قطر يجب تحسين
ظروف العمال قطر تطورت كثيره في مجال لا
ياتي حقوق العمال وكنت على اطلاع على ذلك
كاس العالم 2022 التي ستفتتح غدا في قطر
وستمر حتى الثامن عشر من ديسمبر المقبل
لتكون اول مونديال ينظم في دوله عربيه
ومسلمه وسيكون مئات الملايين من عشاق كره
القدم حول العالم على موعد غدا مع مباراه
الافتتاح بين قطر البلد المنظم والاكوادور
ومع استكمال للاستعدادات هكذا قطر والفيفا
ان هذه النسخه ستكون تاريخيه
واستثنائيه على مستوى المنشات والجوانب
التنظيميه وظروف اجراء المباريات مع
تقنيات وخدمات سيتم استخدامها لاول مره في
تاريخ كاس العالم لكره القدم
لا شبكه مراسلين من منطقه المشجعين في
حديقه البدع بكورنيش الدوحه نور الدين
بوزيان وايضا من مدينه الخور ايمن الزبير
ومن العاصمه الاكوادوريه كيتو حسان مسعود
مرحبا بكم جميعا ابدا معك نور الدين
بوزيان انت في حديقه البدع بكورنيش الدوحه
قل لنا هذه الاجواء لهذه الليله قبيله
الافتتاح
سلمى الاجواء تتحدث عن نفسها ان امام كما
تشاهدين عدد كبير من
المحبين كره القدم من الجمهور الذي جاء
ليس فقط من داخل قطر وانما من مختلف انحاء
العالم لكي يكون شاهدا على ربما افضل
وارقى مونديال في السنوات الاخيره التي
سيبدا غدا همم طبعا هؤلاء منذ تقريبا خمس
ساعات وهم يعيشون هذه الاجواء قبل ذلك
كانت اغاني خاصه من امريكا اللاتينيه حيث
ساطع معها الجمهور والان اغاني عربيه
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه هناك عدد كبير من المشجعين انا
اتيت منذ يومين لم اكن اتوقع ما رايته
اتيت مع بعض الزملاء وبعض الاصدقاء احبوا
قطر واحب كل هذه الاجواء هذه المره الاولى
لك هنا في الدوحه نعم نعم المره الاولى
احببت قطر هذا بلد مختلف لم اكن اتوقع ما
رايت هذا بلد جميل بالفعل
في هذا الجو الاحتفالي بالفعل الاحتفال
ومميز همم يسعدني ان ارى همم هذه الباقه
من الناس من كل انحاء العالم كل شيء مميز
ماذا بالنسبه الى حظوظ المنتخب الانجليزي
اعتقد ان المنتخب لديه فرصه لديه فرصه
بالفعل
استمتع بكاس العالم شكرا هذه بعد
[موسيقى]
الكل يريد ان يفرح بهذا المساء وطبعا
ننتظر المباراه غدا شكرا لك نور الدين
بوزيان وباذهب الان الى منطقه استاد البيت
ايمن
حيث ان سيحفظن هذا الاستاد الضخم همم
مباراه قطر الاكوادور المباراه الاولى
وايضا حرف الافتتاح ضعنا في المواعيد
المجادله اليوم غد
نعم تفصيلنا ساعات قليله ربما عن انطلاق
الفعاليات الرسميه عن الحفل الافتتاحي
والمباراه الافتتاحيه من المتوقع ان ينطلق
الحفل الافتتاحي في الساعه الخامسه
بتوقيت الدوحه وتنطلق المباراه بعد ذلك في
الساعه السابعه صراحه في هذه الساعه
المتاخره لا يمكن الحديث عن الحماس الذي
رصده الزميل نور الدين بوزيان ولكن ذلك لا
يعني ان هنا الهدوء هناك هدوء تامبل
بالعكس هناك استعدادات على قدم وساق صحيح
ان الجاهزيه كامله هنا ولكن
المتطوعون وايضا مئات العمال يقومون
باللمسات الاخيره بالبروفات الاخيره نعلم
ان الحفل الافتتاح
العديد من الفعاليات اللجنه المنظمه تتحدث
عن مفاجات وعن لحظات استثنائيه ستعيشها
جماهير التي ستاتي الى هذا الملعب هنا
ستفتتح الابواب في حدود الساعه الثالثه
لكن رغم ذلك الجهات المنظمه تطالب
الجماهير بالقدوم باكرا علما ان هناك
العديد من التسهيلات هناك العديد من وسائل
النقل التي وضعت رهن اشاره المشجعين
للمجيء الى هذا الملعب ايضا علمنا من جهات
هنا في استاد البيت ان همم هناك حضور او
سيكون هناك حضور اعلامي كبير فقط عدد
المصورين
1500 مصور بالاضافه الى عدد الاعلاميين
الذين سيغطون هذا الحدث الاستثنائي ايضا
يتوقع ان يفوق عدد جماهير الاكوادور سته
الاف ولكن بطبيعه الحال جماهير المنتخب
القطري جماهير العنابي ستملا هذا الملعب
الذي تصل طاقته اسعابيه الى 60,000 متفرج
وبالتالي الكل ينتظر هذه اللحظه
الاستثنائيه لحظه انطلاق مونديال قطر بشكل
الرسمي وبالتالي لم تعد تفصلنا عن هذه
اللحظه التي ينتظرها الجميع سوى سويعات
قليله سننقل لكم حينها الاجواء في محيط
استاد البيت نعم ايمن جميعنا بانتظار هذه
اللحظه المنتظره حقيقه منذ سنوات طويله
اثنى عشرتها سنه ونحن نستعد ونترقب
والاكوادور ايضا تترقب حسان مسعود همم
مباراه غد المباراه الافتتاحيه وانت في
احدى الساحات التي يعرض فيها تعرض هذه
المباراه الافتتاحيه في شاشه عملاقه ضعنا
في تفاصيل هذه الترتيبات والتحضيرات
للاكوادور والاكوادوري
بالفعل سلمى تلك الاجواء التي تحدث عنها
الزملاء هناك في الدوحه نشعر بها هنا ايضا
وسط العاصمه الاكواديريه كيتو حيث تقام
هذه الفعاليات على هامش انتظار المباراه
الكبيره التي ستجمع المنتخب الرابعه
[موسيقى]
همم هنا ينتظر الجميع هذه المباراه
الكبيره همم من المعروف ان الوقت اختلاف
التوقيت كبير بين الاكوادور والدوحه حوالي
ثمان ساعات وهذا الامر غدا ان يحضر
المشاهدون وجمهور الى هذه السحاب عند
الصباح
لذلك نتوقع انه منذ الساعه 7:00 صباحا
ستمتلئ هذه الساحات تحديدا باللون الاصفر
وهو لون الزي الرسمي لان المنتخب
الاكوادور الذين سيجتمعون هنا ويشجعون
فريقهم ويشهدون هذه المباراه القادم في
الصوره من الاكوادور من كيتو من كيتو
نشكرك حسان مسعود اذا من العاصمه
الاكوادريه كيتو ونور الدين زيان كان معنا
من حديقه البدع بالكورنيش الدوحه وايضا من
امام استاد البيت في الخور ايمن الزبير
شكرا لكم جميعا تشيروا التوقعات الانا
خمسه مليارات شخص في انحاء على الارضيه
سيتابعون البطوله الممتده لنحو شهر
والمقاومه لاول مره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
على ارض دوله عربيه مسلمه تقرير فاطمه
اتريكي
20 11 الثاني 2022
نرحب بالجبير في دوحه الجميع حان كاس
العالم العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]
كل قطر
بحر وبعيده تبدو اليوم رحله الاثني عشر
عاما منذ فازت قطر الدوله الخليجيه
العربيه المسلمه عام 2010 باستضافه اكبر
واهم حدث رياضيا في العالم رحله يقول اهل
قطر انها سنوات من التحدي وانهم على وعدهم
بتنظيم ما ياملون ان يكون اجمل نسخه في
تاريخ البطوله تقام لاول مره في الشرق
الاوسط
موجود العرب في كاس العالم كان دوما وجود
ضيف بمشاركه منتخباتهم اثنا عشر مرات منذ
بديها عام
1930 لكنهم اليوم حاضرون باربعه منتخبات
وهم المضيفون والمنظم
[موسيقى]
للمره الاولى سيرى القادمون سحر الشرقي
حيث هو لا مستشرقا او متخيلا مرويا او
مشوهان ويرون ثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه
وعاداتها في اهلها المتباهين بها لا من
تصورات نمطيه مسبقه صنعتها السياسه
والدعايه ويردد المسؤولون القطريون بان
هذا التنظيمه هو باسم كل العرب ومنهم
للعالم اجمع فرصه تتجاوز الرياضه لتلاقي
الثقافات واكتشاف الاخر وكسر الحواجز
الانسانيه في ظلال لوحه هي في معناها شجره
وارفه في الصحراء
وكثيرا من صحراء الرمال الخلابه ذبت فيها
الروح مع نهضه شامله تعرف برؤيه 20 30
ويخطه نهوض في البنيه التحتيه والمشاريع
الضخمه في قطر تضمنت بناء مدن وشبكه
مواصلات حديثه بموازاه تطوير تعليميه
وصحيا جاء كاس العالم في وسط المسيره
لتشهد تسريعا في التنفيذ بكلفه تجاوزت 200
مليار دولار اقله من عشره في المئه منها
كلفه 8 ملاعب سيوهب بعضها لدول فقيره
بينما يبقى العمران والتحديث لاهله الحدث
وفق كثيرين الهام ومثال بالا مستحيله مع
الاراده اما القدره فبالتخطيط والمال وان
قصف بالموارد طبيعيه وبشريه حين تحسن
ادارتها بالنسبه لقطر هذه ما سبب فريده
لتثبيت حضور عالميا مع انظار خمسه مليارات
انسان ستتوجه اليها لمتابعتي كاس اكثر
الرياضات شعبيه في العالم وقت قصير يفصل
عن صفاره البدايه كان سنوات ثم اياما
صدقائق ليشتعل الحماس وتعود ذكريات وتتخلق
التفاصيل نقاش الاهداف والحروب الجميله
على الفراق والنجوم العابرين للحدود
والاعراف والزمن
لشهر ستتخفف الانسانيه من غلوائها وتنشغل
بصراع قانونه فوري نفاذ وميدانه منازلات
وانتصارات لا بطش فيها ولا دماء ليا
ضربهما يعشق الناس كره القدم اذ تمنحهم
عداله تغيب في الحياه وتتحقق في ملعبه حيث
البقاء للافضل لا للاكثر او الاغنام او
الاقوى
[تصفيق]
انضموا الينا من بوسطن المصطفى المرزوقي
رئيس التونسيه السابق السيد المنصف
المرزوقي مرحبا بك معنا
حلما طموحا وباتا واقعا معاشا ملموسا
بجاهزيه عاليه كيف تنظر الى هذا الانجاز
الذي ارادته قطر ان يكون لها ولي العرب
قطر
[موسيقى]
قطر شكرا
يعني الغربيه يعني من بعض الاطراف خاصه عن
بعض الصحف على على هذه التجربه
واتذكر هناك كلمه السيد المسيح الذي يقول
لرونا يعني القشه في عيون الاخرين ولا
يرون العمود الذي في اعينهم شوفي سيد كريم
اذا في شخص يعني يعرف ازدواجات الخطاب في
في البلدان الغربيه هو انا يعني
كيف يدافعون دوما على الديمقراطيه وكيف
يدعمون بكل وقاحه يعني الاستبداد العربي
في كل مكان نسخه ما يقع اليوم في بلدي
للاسف الشديد همم هم ايضا يعني في هذه
الهجمه التي يعني انا اشعر بها كان هاشم
بدي انا شخصيا يعني كعربي يعني شو هال-
يعني ما عندكش الفكر على الفضاء التي
اراها اليوم في الصحف خاصه في الصحف
الموجوده في اوروبا يعني
واضح انه عنده مشكله اساسيه انه يصير فيه
نجاح باهر في دوله عربيه مسلمه وواضح انهم
ايضا يريدون ان يغمى تحقق قطريين انا اقدر
الناس ايضا يعني عندي يعني لحسن الحظ
الاصدقاء من الداخل والله عايش يعني همم
كم تحاول السلطات كم حاولت وكم تحاول يعني
اصله القطريه ان تكون هذه همم يعني هذه
الحفله لا تكون على حساب الفقراء على حساب
المسكين في 2014 انا اعلم انه المجلس
الاعلى القطري يعني وضع خطوط عامه
للمحافظه على صحه العمال انا اعلم انه في
2017 اغنيه الوكاله انا اعلم انه في 2020
يعني صارت في هناك العديد
يعني همم القوانين المعدله لكي تحفظ كرامه
وحقوق العمال في 2021 انا اعلم انه ايضا
صار فيه همم رفع المستوى الداخل لهؤلاء
العمال الى اخره ومع هذا كل هذا العمل
الجبار الذي تقوم به الاداره السياسيه لم
يره اصحابنا هنا في الغرب ويركز على نواقص
وهذه النواقص موجوده في كل عمل البشري وهم
قدر الناس يعرفون انه في كل البلدان التي
فيها الاقتصاد الليبرالي الاراده السياسيه
تسطل دائما وابدا بما تقوم به الشركات
التي تماطل او تحاول او كذا واعلم انه
الاداره السياسيه في في قطر فعل اجبار هذه
الشركات على حق الاحترام حقوق العمال
وبالتالي انا اعتبر ان هذه الهجمه القذره
التي موجوده ضد قطر مرفوضه جمله خاصه تاتي
من هؤلاء الناس المعروفين
المنصف المرزوقي يعني الى اي درجه هذا
الحدث بهذه الجاهزيه وبهذه الروح
الجامعه للحاله الانسانيه
ستؤثر وتغير من حاله التنميط لسوره العرب
التي حاول بعض دعنا نقول بعض الدول
الغربيه ولا نجمعهم جميعا ان يرسخوها الى
الان في الاذهان
نوع من الغيره
يعني كثير من الدول وليس فقط من الدول
الغربيه لنجاح دوله عربيه مسلمه ولنجاح
قطر وخاصه
يعلمون انه همم قطر همم تعول على ذاتها
تعول على طاقاتها الى اخره وهم لا يريدون
في الواقع للاسف الشديد النجاح لبلدان
وتميز قطر في الوقت الحاضر ايه يجعلهم
يراجعون كل همم كل افكارهم حول تفوقهم
المزعوم الان واضح انه همم يعني مدن
المستقبل وحركات المستقبل لم تعود موجوده
فقط في الغرب موجوده ايضا في كل مكان مره
اخرى انا اعتبر انه ما يقع اليوم هو
التشجيع لكل بلدان العالم الثالث للعرب
والمسلمين نستطيع ان نقوم بكل المعجزات
نستطيع ان نتغلب على كل العقبات لانه في
ضرب 10 سنوات يعني انظر ما فعلته قطر وانا
اعتبر انه فعلا هناك درس يجب ان تتعلم منه
كل الشعوب وهو انه الاراده السياسيه
والذكاء وليس فقط الامكانيه الماديه لان
كثير من البلدان لها امكانيه الماديه
واكثر من الامكانيات الماديه عندها قطر
لكن عندما تكون هناك الذكاء ونعتبر ان
هناك كثير من الذكاء وهنا الكثير من
الاراده السياسيه
بالاتجاه الصحيح ان نفعل هذه المعجزات
لماذا تدلل شهاده
الدوليه
يعني علق وقال عن هذه الهجمه بانها دروس
اخلاقيه تنوم عن النفاق وتحدث عن معايير
مزدوجه برايك ما هي الدلاله الرئيسيه لمثل
هذا التوصيل
هناك اعتقد انه في كثير من العنصريه
ثقافيه التي مازالت متغلله هناك كثير من
الحسد هناك كثير من الغيره ومره اخرى ليست
هناك ادنى مصداقيه لان مثل ما قلت لك انا
اعرف الخطاب ازدواجات الخطاب في السياسه
يتحدثون على الديمقراطيه في شراء اخرى
يعني يمارسون او يدعمون الاستبداد
والديكتاتوريه في كل مكان معروف انا اعتقد
انه كما يقول الشاعر
اتفضلوا ابحثوا في زلاتنا يعني سنتعلم
وسنتها لان مره اخرى هناك ثقه سياسيه
لتفادي كل هذه اللات بالعكس احنا من هذه
يعني الضغط الممارسه علينا المنافسه ستكون
هي همم
البلدان العربيه وليس فقط لا مره اخرى مش
قضيه ماده هناك كثير من البلدان موجوده
عندها ماده وليس لها للاراده السياسيه
والذكاء السياسي اللي يخلي قطر اليوم تفتح
طريق يعني للامه اعتبر انه طريق همم طريق
الامل السياسه
[موسيقى]
وصل رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشه سوناك
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف زياره لم يعلن
عنها مسبقا وهي زيارتها الاولى لاوكرانيا
والتقى هناك
الذي قال في حسابه
انه هو منذ الايام الاولى للحرب كانت
اوكرانيا وبريطانيا حليفتين قويتين واضاف
انه ناقشه مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني خلال
اجتماع اليوم اهم القضايا بالنسبه للبلدين
وللامن العالمي واشاره زيلين
معا اقوى وسوف يحققان نتائج المرجوعه
هذا واكد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك كان بلاده ستستمر في تقديم دعمها
العسكري لاوكرانيا كما اعلن عن تزويد كيف
بانظمه جديده للدفاع الجوي تتضمن 120
مدفعيه مضاده للطائره
وحده مليارين و 300 مليون جنيه استرليني
من الدعم العسكري وسنفعل شيئا نفسه مره
العام القادم بينما تنجحون في سد القوات
الروسيه على الارض تتدمر منازلكم
ومستشفياتكم ومحطات الطاقه لديكم
ولمساعدتكم في الدفاع عن انفسكم نقدم
اليوم حزمه دعم جديده للدفاع الجوي بما في
ذلك مئه وعشرون وحده مدفعيه مضاده
للطائرات
ومعدلات مضاده للطائرات
وخلال استقبال هي رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
قال رئيس الاوكراني فلود ميرسيلنسكي ان
الهجمات الروسيه على منشات الطاقه في
اوكرانيا تستهدف وقفه صادراتها من الطاقه
لاوروبا وقطع الصراط بها واضاف زنسكي ان
كله هجوم الروسيه على منشات الطاقه وفعليا
هجوم على اوروبا
اوكرانيا قادره على توليد الطاقه ليس
لاحتياجاتها فقط بل كذلك كنا نصدر الطاقه
الى السوق الاوروبيه وفق الاتفاقات
المشتركه الهجمات الروسيه صممت لقطع هذه
الروابط مع اوروبا فكله هجوم على منشات
الطاقه في اوكرانيا الان هو فعليا هجوم
على اوروبا باكملها
وقال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني بدوره
بمتريكوليبا ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى نصر
وليس الى تعادل ونقل بيان عن كليب قوله
انه اذا سمح لروسيا باخذ استراحه الانفوتا
سيخلق صراعا مجمدا في وسط اوروبا ونشد
خليفه
عندما او شركاء اوكرانيا عدم وضع محادثات
سلامه مبكرا مع روسيا هدفا لهم بل ان يجعل
هدفهم هو انتصار اوكرانيا وحذر كليبا
شركاء اوكرانيا من عرض تنازلات تمسك وحده
الاراضيه وسياده الاخرانيه لان هذا سيكون
بمثابه تنازلاهم عن امن بلادهم بشكل مباشر
حسب تعبيره
من جانبه قال اندريا كبير مساعد رئيس
الاوكراني بلود ميرسي ان السلامه مع روسيا
لن يكون ممكنا الى عندما يتم تدمير الجيش
الروسي وتستعيد اوكرانيا حدود عام
1991 وتشمل حدود عام 91 من القرن الماضي
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه الاربع التي اعلنت
روسيا ضمها من جانب واحد الى جانب شبه
جزيره القرم
وفي موسكو قال رئيس لجنه الشؤون الدوليه
بانها لم تغلق باب التفاوض مع اوكرانيا
ولا ترفض مواصله المفاوضات واضاف المسؤول
الروسي ان الرئيس الاوكراني لا يهتموا
بالمفاوضات وقال ان المؤشر الكبير على ذلك
هو محاولته جر نيته الى صراع مع روسيا بعد
حادث سقوط صواريخ في بولندا وشدد المسؤول
الروسي على ان قرار استئناف المفاوضات
يتخذوا في واشنطن مهما قيل ان الامر متروك
لاوكرانيا وفقا تعبير
في موسكو ايضا قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي مدري فان الغربه السائمه من
سلوك رئيس الاوكراني
الذي يستمر بطلب من الغرب ارسال مزيدا من
المال والاسلحه عبر خطابات مليئه بالمشاعر
حسب تعبيره واضاف مدفيدف ان الولايات
المتحده واحل فشنال الاطلسي لا يريدان
قطيعه كامله مع روسيا ولهذا فانهما
يحاولان دفع كيف لمزيدا من العقلانيه حسب
قوله
افاده حكم واقليم في روسيا بوقوعي انفجار
في خط الانابيب الغاز بالاقليم ووافق شهود
عيان لحظه وقوع الانفجار الضخم ونقلت
وسائل اعلام الروسيه عن حاكم لنجراد انه
لا يوجد خطر على السكان بينما يجري العمل
على تحديد اسباب الانفجار
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها قتلت
اكثر من 120 اوكرانيا في مقاطعه دوناتس
وذكر المتحدث باسم الوزاره
من الجيش الاوكراني والمرتزقه قتلو خلال
صدها للقوات الاوكرانيه في بلده اوكرانيه
ابراهيم ابراهيم
بعد ذلك بعدما اعلنت كوريا الجنوبيه ان
كوريا الشماليه اطلقت ما يبدو انه صاروخ
بالسيون عابر للقارات وقال مسؤولون ياباني
200 كيلو متر فقط من اليابان
تزداد الاوضاع العسكريه في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه توترا يوما بعد يوم
قذفات امريكيه من طراز بي 1 بي تحلق في
السماوات كوريه الجنوبيه ضمن تدريبات جويه
مشتركه بين البلدين جرد هذه التدريبات بعد
اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخا بالسجن عابرا
للقارات باشراف زعيمها
على خلفيات التحالف الامريكي بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده ولبان
[موسيقى]
والصاروخ هو الاحدث في سلسله من عمليات
الاطلاق التي تجريها بيونيانج اخيرا وهو
من اسلحتها الاستراتيجيه واطلق من منطقه
السنان في بيونيانج وقطع مسافه 1000 كم
ووصل ارتفاعه الى 6000 كيلو متر وسقط في
البحر على بعد 200 كيلو متر من اليابان
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي وصف التدريبات
العسكريه الامريكيه الكوريه الجنوبيه
بانها مناورات حرب عدوانيه هستيريه تستهدف
غزو بلاده وتعاهد بالرد بحزم وباسرحه
النوويه في حال استخدام السلاح النووي ضد
بلاده
القوه الامريكيه واليابانيه اجرت ايضا
تدريبات مماثله ووصف وزير الدفاع الياباني
يا ساكارها ماذا اطلاق الصاروخ الكوري
الشمالي بانه عمل طائش وقال ان بلاده
ستواصل التعاون الامني مع السهول واشنطن
الشمالي قد اعلن في سبتمبر الماضي ان
بلاده كرست رسميا سياسه تجعل من وضعها
النووي امرا لا رجعه فيه ومنذ اذن كسفت
واشنطن التدريبات مع السهول وطوكيو وبين
هذه تلك التي جرت معزول في اواخر اكتوبر
الماضي
من ناحيه اخرى اطلاق الصاروخ الكوري
الشمالي خيم على اجواء قمه
عقدتنا هبه الرئيس الامريكي كما لهاريس
اجتماعا مع قاده اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا وكندا وذكر ان
واشنطن ستطلب مساعده الحليف الابرز الكوري
الشماليه من اجل ذبح جمال
يتجدد التوتر في شبه جزيره الكوريه
باستمرار منذ فشل قيمتها نوي عام 2019
وتتوجس واشنطن وشون و طوكيو من انبيونيانج
تستفيد من اطاله امد النزاع في استئناف
تجاربها النوويه وانها قطعت شوطا بعيدا في
ذلك
الامن الدولي اجتماعا يوم الاثنين المقبل
لبحثه الملف الكوري الشمالي بعد التجربه
الصاروخيه الاخيره
بالعوده الى ملف الحرب الروسي على
اوكرانيا وحديث الاسلحه وحديث المفاوضات
ينضم الينا من اوصله
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
معنا
الرغبه الاوروبيه دعنا نقول الامريكيه
وحلف الناتو باستمراريه ذات الزخم
في دعم كيف الامدادات بالاسلحه من اجل
حربيها
والصمد
يتراجع لاسباب متعدده ومن بين هذه الاسباب
هي ان حلف شمال الاطلسي والغرب تنفذ منه
الاسلحه مخزون الاسلحه
وبالتالي هذا يبدو وكانه يقود الى ان تميل
الدفه باتجاه روسيا المشكله الثانيه هي
المشكله الاقتصاديه ونعني بها هنا بشكل
اساسي الازمه في مجال الطاقه والاقتصاد
والازمه الماليه في اوروبا باضافه الى
الهجره الجماعيه وموجات من اللاجئين سوف
تصلوا من اوكرانيا الى اوروبا في القريب
العاجل وهذه الامور تؤذي الاوروبيين بشكل
اكبر من الامريكيين ولذلك تبدو اوروبا
انها على جاهزيه اكثر لوضعه حد لهذه الحرب
بان هذه اللحظه مواتيه همم من خلال هذه
الاجواء وهذه النقاط التي تحدثت عنها لبدا
مفاوضات بالرغم من رفض اوكراني وتشديد
ومناشدا للاوربيين والامريين بعدم الدفع
باتجاه المفاوضات حاليا
[موسيقى]
المفاوضات اولا المساله المتعلقه
باوكرانيا الرئيس زينسكي سنه قانونا يجعل
من غير قانوني ان تتفاوض اوكرانيا مع
روسيا وهناك شروط متعدده لاطلاق عجله
المفاوضات
والمشكله الثانيه اذا ما بدا ذلك بتفاوض
مع روسيا هناك
مجموعات
نازيه جديده من اليمين في اوكرانيا قد
تستهدف عدد كبير من القاده العسكريين في
اوكرانيا لا يرضى بهذا المسار مشكله
اضافيه هي شكل المفاوضات بالنسبه الى
روسيا النقطه الرئيسه
شمال الاطلسي ولكن هذا امر صعب بالنسبه
الى الناتو حيث انه يبدو وكانه يهدي روسيا
هديه مقابل
تجاوز سعر الدولار الواحد في السوق
الموازيه
36,000 ريال ايراني ويرجعوا يرجعوا
المسؤولون وخبراء ابرز اسباب الانخفاض الى
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد وانحسار
الامال برفع العقوبات نتيجه توقف
المفاوضات النوويه
يفلت مره اخرى عقال العمله الوطنيه في
ايران يسجل الريال مستوى غير مسبوق
متجاوزا سته 36000 للدولار الواحد كذلك
اخر مشهد في انحدار استمر منذ فرض
العقوبات الامريكيه على الاقل
خسرت فيه العمله الايرانيه كثيره من
قيمتها
اكثر اسباب هذا الهبوط التاريخي الجديد في
البلاد تعيش ازمه احتجاجات دخلت شهرها
الثاني تقول وزاره الاقتصاد ان ذلك دفع
مواطنين لتحويل جزء من مدخاراتهم الى
الدولار
[تصفيق]
مع اخر خارجي تمثل في توقف المفاوضات
النوويه
برفع العقوبات
وزادت الطين بالله عقوبه اوروبيه وامريكيه
على خلفيه الاحتجاجات واتهام ايران بتزويد
روسيا بالمسيرات
لاستخدامها في حربها على اوكرانيا لكن ثم
تمي يقولوا في البرلمان ان العزه في
الموازنه البالغ نحو سبعه مليارات دولار
دفع الحكومه الى رفع سعر الدولار
في الموازنه واللجوء الى التلاعب باسعار
العملات في السوق ليس الحلال انجح والافضل
تقديم خطه اقتصاديه لانقاذ الوضع
المركزي للسيطره على السوق العملاء
فاتح شراء الدولار عبر قنوات الرسميه
الكترونيه
واعلنت السلطات اعتقال عشرات مما وصفتهم
بممثلين الاضطرابات في السوق واغلاق مئات
الحسابات المصرفيه بالعمله الاجنبيه
تمثل علاجا مؤقتا وهبوط العمله الوطنيه
سيتواصلوا مع غياب التنميه الاقتصاديه
في ايران يرتفع معدل التضخم ويزداد معه
الضغط الاقتصادي على المواطن اثار تتضاعف
مع وصول التضخم والبطاله الى ارقام قياسيه
وامنيه وسياسيه واقتصاديه تسجل العمله في
ايران هبوطا جديدا لتزيد الضغوط على
المواطن وتضع الحكومه امام تحديات جديده
عمر هواش الجزيره طيران
نعود الى اجوائك كاس العالم قطر 2022
انطلاقه اول مباريات المونديال معكم بعضا
من المحطات الرئيسيه في تاريخ البطوله
الذي تجاوز 90 عاما وما ان يذكر تاريخ
يذكر تاريخ كاس العالم يحضر اسم المحامي
الفرنسي جوني
فقد عمل جاهدا انطلاقا من عام
لتنظيم بطوله عالميه لكره القدم في تاريخ
المونديال يشار الى الخامس والعشرين من
مايو عام
1928 باعتبار لحظه تاريخيه ففي هذا اليوم
عقد اجتماع تم فيه الاقرار باطلاق بطوله
كاس النصر او كاس جورما
الاوروجواي استضافت في عام
1930 اولا نسخه من كاس العالم ودخل
هبقى الاوروغواي التاريخ كاول من توج بكاس
النصر او ما يسمى حاليا بكاس العالم سلمت
كاس جورميه للفائزين ببطوله كاس العالم
انطلاقا من نسخته عام
1930 وحتى عام
1970 وتزامنا مع كاس العالم
1974 الذي اقيم في المانيا تم تسليم الرمز
الجديد والحالي لكاس العالم بطبيعه الحال
تشير الاحصائيات الى هيمنه قارتي اوروبا
وامريكا الجنوبيه على منافسات كاس العالم
لكره القدم لكن ما الذي تحمله صفحات
التاريخ للعرب في البطوله
العام الحالي ذات لحظه تاريخيه ومحطه
الرئيسيه في تاريخ البطوله فقط اصبحت دوله
قطر اول دوله في الشرق الاوساط وفي العالم
العربي تفوز بشرف استضافه نهائيات كاس
العالم الارقام تذكروننا ايضا با منتخب
المصري هو اول منتخب عربي يشارك في كاس
العالم وكان ذلك في ايطاليا في عام
1934 اما اول انتصار عربي في كاس العالم
كان بتوقيع المنتخب التونسي في كاس العالم
الارجنتين عام
1978 وكان امام منتخب المكسيك بنتيجه
نتيجه ثلاثه مقابل واحد وتشير ايضا سجلات
التاريخ الى ان المنتخب المغربي هو اول
منتخب عربي يتاهل للدور الثاني وكان ذلك
في المكسيك عام
1986 وتتصدر تونس والسعوديه والمغرب قائمه
المنتخبات العربيه صاحبه اكبر عدد من
المشاركات في بطوله كاس العالم بالحضور في
ست النسخه من المونديال على كل المزيد
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو السيد حميد
كياني وهو الكاتب والصحفي الرياضي حميد
مرحبا بك معنا معنا في بطوله
التي بطوله غدا المنتظره التي ستبدا غدا
نعد الساعات والدقائق لهذه البطوله وهذه
الجاهزيه حدثنا عن ابرز واهم مالفتك
كمتابع وصحفي رياضي
نعيش نحن المقيمين على دوله على ارض دوله
قطر من 12 سنه عرفنا انه بكره راح يكون هو
يوم الافتتاح لمونديال قطر اول مونديال
دوله عربيه دوله مسلمه دوله شرق اوسطيه
وبالتالي هذا انجاز كبير كثير انجاز كان
منتظر فبتلاقينا نحن بنعيش لحظات تاريخيه
بكل ما تحمله تحمله الكلمه من معنى قطر
جاهزه تماما باللحظه الحاليه لاستضافه حدث
ربما هو الاكبر في تاريخ كل الرياضات قطر
جاهزه من حيث المنشات من حيث
الاستعداد الكامل في كل ما يتعلق بحضور
الجماهير الى دوله قطر وشفنا اجواء حماسيه
اجواء احتفاليه اليوم بافتتاح اكثر من همم
فانزون والتحديدا فيفا فستيفال وشفنا كميه
الناس الموجوده بقطر اللي جاءت من خارج
دوله قطر والسعاده الكبيره على وجوه كل من
يعيش على ارض دوله قطر
بانتظارا ل- لحظه بدايه كاس العالم في
الغد حميد همم هذه الاحتفاليه هذه
المناسبه هي ليست فقط كرويه وانما هي ايضا
ثقافيه وحضاريه وانسانيه همم حاولت ان
تطعمها قطر بنكهه عربيه هذه النكهه كيف
رصدتها ان كان من الشعار الى التميمه
تميمه همم المونديال الى كل التفاصيل
الاخرى التي همم وضعت فيها قطر البصمه
القطريه العربيه
امام الاعلام كان دائما يتم ذكر كلمه
عربيه وليست فقط قطريه فقط قطر حاولت
جاهده همم انه ترسخ فكره انه قطر دوله
اسلاميه دوله عربيه ودوله شرقيه حتى من
شكل الاستعدادت ملاعب كره القدم كان فيها
كثير من الاشياء التي تدل على عربيتنا
بشكل عام فشفنا فعلا همم حتى من خلال
تفاصيل همم كل ما يتعلق بالاستادات بالشعر
البطوله قطر فعلا كانت حريصه تماما على
ايصال فكره انه العرب عندهم ثقافه وحضاره
تاريخيه جدا وانا متاكد انه الغرب يعلم
جيدا حضاره وتاريخ العرب لكن قطر حاول
التفكير لجميع مره جديده من خلال كل
المؤتمرات الصحفيه وكل فرصه سنه حيث لان
التذكير الجميع خاصه الغرب بوجود ثقافه
تاريخيه لربما هي الاعمق
التي بعثتها قطر بهذه الجاهزيه وهذه
الشهادات التي جرى الحديث عنها من اهم
وابرز الرياضيين همم وشغلين في هذا صناعه
الرياضه خاصه صناعه كره القدم
واضحه جدا وكانت صريحه جدا ونحن كنا بحاجه
الى شخص غربي لكن صريح وصادق مع نفسه ومع
شعبه ومع القاره لانه دائما في نظره
دنيويه من الغرب الى العرب عن قدرتنا على
تنظيم احداث على هذا المستوى العالي جدا
بل انه نحن تفوقنا على استضافات كثير من
الدول الغربيه والامريكيه الجنوبيه
فبالتالي كان في كثير همم دعم غربي من
لاعبين باريزين مهمين من رئيس الهرم
الكروي في العالم عن قطر استعداد قطر وعن
كل شيء جميل في هذه المدينه
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله ان يشاركوا
معكم هذه اللحظه التاريخيه بعد ساعات من
الان متابعه ما هو اكثر من حدث رياضي
تتنفس فيه فرق من 32 بلدا للظفر بكاس
العالم المونديال يتجاوز كره القدم ويحظى
باهتمام محبي اللعبه الشعبيه الاولى وايضا
غير المهتمين بكره القدم او حتى الرياضه
عموما هو حدث يختلط فيه الرياضيه
بالحضاري بالانساني بالاقتصادي ويحمل
رسائل محبه وسلام وتعارف بين الشعوب
والثقافه تنطلقوا من ارض قطر اولي بلاد
عربيه ومسلم يستضيف
نهائيات كاس العالم لكره القدم الحدث
الرياضي الاهم عالميا نتمنى للجميع اقامه
طيبه ومتابعه شيقه دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]